although the proud and wealthy city of
volantis is proclaimed as one of the
nine free cities there are five slaves
for every free man there it is tradition
in volantis that slaves must be marked
according to status a horse head on the
cheek of stable workers a single tear
beneath the right eye of sex workers
squares of motley from neck to scalp for
fools and jesters it was Aerys Targaryen
that sent Steffon Baratheon on the
voyage to the free city of old volantis
to volantis to find a maiden of old
Valyrian blood to be coined to Rhaegar
Targaryen Stefan found no such girl
instead he sent backward to storms in
that he had found a fool it was not
until Stefan ship the wind prod was
inside of storms in that it was caught
in a freak storm Stefan's ships sank
into the shipbreaker bay whilst his
children watched helplessly from the
castle there was only one survival the
fool called patch face but strange were
the circumstances surrounding his
survival hatch face his body washed up
three days after the storm had done its
damage Johnny who was a man in service
of house Baratheon found him on the
shores of storms in what happened next
haunted Johnny until the end of his days
the boy was dead no different from the
other corpses Johnny and the others had
been sent to reclaim cold wrinkled and
pale but when Johnny grabbed his ankles
the boy's eyes opened he spat up the
water in his lungs and sat straight up
they would come to find that the boy's
memories were gone he was not the witty
child that lured Stefan had spoke of in
his letter to Crescent just a fortnight
before only a boy yet nimble as a monkey
and witty as a dozen Court years he is
described by Stefan as nimble as a
monkey and witty as a dozen courtiers
but after the shipwreck both his mind
and body happened bro
he was soft and obese subject to
twitches Trimble's incoherent often is
not at Dragonstone where there is the
princess Shireen there is patch face
never munch attention is drawn to him
yet he stands out there is something
about him that is unnerving to the
reader more than his simple mind
something that feels dare I say
insidious the prologue of a Clash of
Kings is toed from the point of view of
maester Cressen a withering old man
whose influence on Dragonstone is being
threatened by the arrival of the red
priestess Melisandre Cresson desperately
hopes to defeat Melisandre and her
strange foreign God and eventually
resources to poison he fails Milla
saundra stays with Stannis and remains
an influence while crescents influence
and life ends with the prologue but we
can't say he wasn't warned the child's
mouth gaped open it talks a few words as
I said they are clever these birds
clever bird clever man clever clever
fool said patch face jangling Oh clever
clever clever fool he began to sing the
shadows come to dance my lord dance my
lord dance my lord
he's sing hopping from one foot to the
other and back again the shadows come to
stay my lord stay my lord stay my lord
he jerked his head with each word the
bells in his antlers sending up a
clinger patch face refers to Crescent as
a clever man but he refers to himself as
a clever clever fool implying that he's
more clever than Crescent he then goes
on to speak about dancing shadows coming
to stay this is not the first time that
dancing shadows are mentioned in our
story during mirror master spell
Daenerys witnesses dancing shadows in
Drago's tin Mary claims that she has
learned these skills from shadow bombers
at a shy there are only two characters
in our story that are referred to as
shadow bynars quake and Melisandre we
know from our story that Melisandre has
the ability to manipulate shadows and
in ways that others cannot she can birth
creatures and send them out into the
night
through her bidding she could use
shadows in ways which allow her to
change her appearance and the appearance
of others so in patch face mentions the
shadows coming to dance and shadows
coming to stay is he referring to
Melisandre this seems more likely than
not we know from a dance with dragons at
Melisandre fears patch face and believes
him to be ultimately destructive that
creature is dangerous many times I have
glimpsed him in my flames sometimes
there are skulls about him and his lips
are red with blood what is it about
patch face that could be so dangerous
what Camilla Sandra's vision referred to
in A Song of Ice and Fire the drowned
God is worshipped on the Iron Islands
drowning and resurrection are key parts
of their religious rituals to be drowned
is to be given to the drowned God and to
be resurrected is to be born again from
the sea for what his dead may never die
but rises again harder and stronger but
the Ironborn do not truly die
they simply deprive themselves of oxygen
for a brief moment and are quote-unquote
resurrected by a process we would in our
world call cardiopulmonary resuscitation
but patch face actually drowned if Jame
can be believed he was dead he was
swallowed by the sea given to the
drowned God and brought back
the storm that took Steffon Baratheon
ship was a sudden one they were
unprepared and it cost them dearly but a
sinking ship
is no strange thing and shipbreaker bay
its capricious weather and sharp jagged
rocks are the stuff of legend patch
faces survival itself has become the
subject of much discussion amongst the
fisher folk of the Stormlands according
to their own urban legends a Merlin
taught him to breathe underwater in
return for his seed stories of Merlin's
are common amongst the Westerosi who
live near the sea especially in places
like white Harbor and the Iron Islands
according to the Ironborn there are
mermaids who live in the drowned gods
watery holes and attend to him legends
of the Shivering sea describe mermaids
with pale skin at black scales said to
be far more devious and evil than their
cousins to the south
patch face often refers to merfolk and
life under the sea in his songs and
riddles are they the ramblings of a man
whose wits had long been lost or are
they Stroud at truths under the sea men
marry fishes hatch face did a little
dance step jingling his bells they do
they do they do if it's true that patch
face gave his seed to a Merlin in the
song he sings here seems to fit this
would also parallel another legend and a
saga by some fire The Legend of the
night's king who gave his seed to a
woman that was pale and cold as ice and
with his seed he gave her his soul he
was bound to her for 13 years until
Jorma and the king of winter brought an
end to it could patch face half as well
given his soul to the Merlin if Merlin's
exists and patch face is bound to them
then what could be his goal take a
closer look at his riddles and songs and
you will find that it seems that he
desires to return to the sea not only to
return to the sea but to bring the
princess Shireen with him
I will lead it his bells rang merrily we
will march into the sea and out again
under the ways we will ride seahorses
and mermaids will blow seashells to
announce our coming oh oh oh away away
The Fool sing come with me beneath the
sea away away away he took the little
princess by one hand and drew her from
the room skipping but what use could the
Merlin's have for princess Shireen
throughout Westeros they're legends of
being is called squishers squishers are
scaled and fishy-smelling humanoids with
webbed hands and feet and teeth as sharp
as needles they are said to come by
night and steal children the girls they
keep to breed with the boys they are set
to eat on toad Isle of Essos there are a
race of people who claim to have been
descended from some humanoid fish
creature the people have webbed hands
and webbed feet and disturbingly
fish-like faces they worship an idol
made from black stone that's also said
to have been built by the creatures long
gone the creatures that they describe as
their ancestors sing very similar to
some of the other descriptions of sea
folk so there is evidence that these
so-called squishers do and have bred
with humans that means that the idea
that pache face gave his seed to a
merlin may not be as dubious as it
sounds it may also have other
implications just about everything we
know about the Merlin's and the
squishers is based on hearsay and legend
we have two independent sources that
tell us one thing however Merlin's breed
with humans and so do the so called
squishers it seems likely to me that it
is accurate to say that the legends of
the squishers and the merlynx refer to
the same beings the deep ones this idea
is backed up by the claims of maester
Theron of the Iron Islands they're on
argue that the legends of the merlynx
are actually in reference to the deep
ones these sea dwelling creatures are
known even in Lovecraftian lore from
which Martin has borrowed them from to
breed with humans this means that there
is a rather glaring possibility
that the purpose of Patch face is to
claim Shireen for the sea Steffon
Baratheon had no daughters only sons
three sons Stannis windley and Robert if
Stannis died
Shireen will be the rightful heir to the
Seven Kingdoms I have made several
connections between multiple artifacts
of Blackstone throughout the world and
the deep ones it seems that they
inhabited the world long before men ever
did it is claimed by some that these
creatures were destroyed by the first
men this seems unlikely to me however
there is evidence of conflicts between
mankind and these creatures the maze
makers of Laura were said to have been
destroyed by foes that came from the sea
the high tower of Old Town sits upon a
black stone that's more ancient in the
town itself the Isle it rests upon is
named battle Isle the reason for the
name is lost in time conflict between
men and the deep waters fits into the
themes of men versus nature that are
constant in our story while the
artifacts of the deep ones remain they
have seemingly vanished I do not believe
it is likely that they are extinct
however much like the children of the
forest they simply have retreated into
their natural habitat to flee humanity
back into the sea they have gone
Shireen's purpose is to breed with them
to give them heirs with the blood of
kings so that they themselves could lay
claim to Westeros but this would all
have to wait until Shireen was old
enough which has to be the reason that
patch face has not made his move yet he
must wait until she is a woman and then
and only then would he be free to take
her with him back into the sea thank you
guys for watching make sure you like and
subscribe for more ideas of Ice and Fire